Please listen to me, Paladin of the Urubashi
[Music]
With the future held up far
away Even if it continues beyond the light, the
truth continues to be small
[Music] No matter how far I go if it's dazzling, I'll
move on I
write as a minstrel.  Idols are essentially financial poets,
and they don't just sing songs; they
write and sing poems about the beauty and preciousness of the things they see and hear in this world, and sometimes about the folly of human beings, as they travel.  My
encounter with Paladin-sama made me want to
become a true idol.I want to become someone who can
inspire and support people who fight like them.
[Music]
[Applause]